alors philippe léotard bonsoir bush ou
alors tu nous fais un 33 tours qui
s'appelle à l'amour comme à la guerre
ouais c'est très bien alors parole de
qui par hasard puis plus tard jazz et la
musique et la musique soufie du charbon
ouais directeur musical servane oui
c'est aujourd'hui au tour il faut lui
dire tu vas nous faire un peu de [ __ ]
oui à la cigale corps le 23 mai le 23
une fourmi et la cigale et le cinéma
alors tu en connais on va continuer dans
la promo fin d année où la vue qu'on est
là débat toujours lellouche ouais mon
amie de coeur ouais y'a traque qui va
sortir dans un séjour oui elle s'appelle
plutôt à une arme s'appelle le
le camion le grand ribaud à le grand
ruban je vais faire exemple dans le
tournage a fait une enquête de mise
auprès des chauffeurs routiers des poids
lourds et la route ils appellent ça le
grand loto de trois camions jamie le
patin ouais il état d'expressions comme
ça quoi et alors la scène le théâtre de
la roquette
oui terrier novembre dans les repères et
je commence en principe pour novembre
les recettes de ces mystérieux je suis
ici un bon train en quatre langues de
jouer le spectacle en français et en
anglais en espagnol en russe jusqu'à 93
et c'est la seule hésitation ce qui
n'est pas sûr soit possible de celui
d'un roman il s'appellera taux de 5
jeudi
c'est tiré de ces normands adapté mais
je suis aussi logés comme si nous fera
prendre pas pu rembourser la pause
l'acide mensuel et j'ai commencé les
trois mois et doit commencer à répéter
en septembre je suis pas changé c'est
encore et toujours le murin
une base mais est un enfer parce que ma
rationnelle et producteurs ce que tu dis
bon courage à la paix érigent permet de
faire qu'il ya au canada ouais
sur toile à le fondu enchaîné jour mou
du genou bon alors est ce que tu es prêt
j'ai de faire une interview à peine down
on y tient
la plus grande joie de ta carrière
césar quand j'ai compris qu'ils
n'étaient pas truqués
ouais c'est bien là mais bon je voulais
un baquet après j'ai passé trois ans en
prison
voilà ça fait toujours rien je paie à
mais moralement
la plus grande déception de près car à
part les trois ans où tu rester sans
travail et un nouveau tueur à gages lui
serait alors le plus grand moment de ta
vie marc est ce que c'est pas tu sais
quand tu tu restais mort un moment
pendant car à ce jeu le plus beau qu'est
ce qui s'est passé là vous me dis que
c'est un moment d'une volupté intense
finalement a chuté martinique enfin
c'était là oui j'ai eu peur j'ai eu une
overdose de spirit et moulages va abuser
de la non je suis pas je vois de
médicaments mais il se forme j'ai eu une
pareille du diaphragme et puis
heureusement que c'était une scène une
cascade donc j'avais les pompiers eh oui
si le malawi est arrivé pitallier ce
risque
j'avais bien qui me prêtent attention
aux fidji et 9,8
c'était bon pour le congé kaka pour se
terminer à 3 5 litres
c'était beau c'est à dire ouais mais
disons c'est bien conservés vous dit pas
mais
alors johnny weir mais dans la vie le
plus beau moment de ta vie maintenant
donc quand tu es mort sciemment par an
et encore j'ai la lumière ouais c'est
lui alors le plus mauvais maintenant
c'est quand je chéris du coma a vu la
gueule de tout déçu même si banny
caissons de plastique dans le nez m
oxygène question un peu plus personnelle
encore plus personnel ce que tu préfères
dans le sexe le bout les bêtes ce qu'on
voit pas mais j'aime bien je suis
bestiaux est-ce que tu détestes debout
jean les blues in on compte que je fais
à pour la libération des confrères le
genre mes chances de fibres soumettre
les pompiers claude les collants des
angines que je te paye cricket en
carburant alors dis-moi léotard ce que
tu aimes le plus sans toi devant le tass
mon frère moi cible chute je suivais
mlle plusieurs mois c'est la gonzesse
tant côté gonzesse qui joue à broadway
nous violons la région à ce que c'est
inconscient ce qu'il décide à la place
jules guesde l'instinct qui est un gros
con avec les chiens
est ce que tu aimes le mois le moins à
ce que tu aimes le mois on voit ce que
tu détestes chez toi ma gueule en quelle
attaque avait été déjà arrivé pour le
wiiware ce que tu préfères dans le
métier d'acteur
ces qualités on travaille tout le temps
je crois qu'ils jouent
c'est mon travail à moi c'est la vie
c'est vrai que des fois je passe une
fois encore tu récites et dans les bars
la nuit des poèmes de lautréamont à des
[ __ ] pour voir quand est ce qu elles
s'aperçoivent que c'est un poème et que
c'est pas toi qui lis ce soit est
fantastique pour halak alors bien sûr
que ça tous les jours tu fais encore
tous les jours ça se dit tous les jours
parisienne
ouais et bon puis petit à petit j'ai pu
j'ai eu plusieurs vies - je suis sale
découvrir rouge les bourses au fond ils
me regardent bovine alors je dire ça à
des macros et des copines dans une villa
ni à 7 heures du matin en chantant il
s'aperçoit au bout de combien de temps
c'est le temps presse et montech est
alors égale oui au bio dans la coque
serait la poésie ou gtalk pas après ça
que je reviendrai jamais qu'il dise des
[ __ ] c'est notre amour donc ça nous
avons personne ne le dis à personne m'a
dit et ça donc moi aussi j'ai oublié ce
que tu détestes dans le métier d'acteur
les joueuses l'acteur fut un écrivain
favori
autres options un show la cidéral le
temps de l'analyse le livre qu'ils vont
faire une idée n a en effet pas coller
sauf par les gousses étant la nuit ça
s'en venait mais parce que bon bah je
rêvais indéfiniment mais comme ça peut
faire vous avez un événement ou alors
louis 20 à 70 il fut alors le portrait
ne partirait de l'artiste mais le
portrait de l'artiste jaune et rouge bon
yaya nano qui devait venir la clinique
de la raison pure bus way non mais le
premier le projet l'artiste nez rouge a
été retardé et diminuer atrophiée à
cause du grand ami à moi j'en ai dernier
carré on va en parler de gens regardent
aller au camp nou vé cité tricasse
nathan devenu je voulais c'est pas ça
c'est que quand tu étais à normale sup
j'avais écrit un pamphlet contre
solaires sur les gens et dans l'allier
qui s'appelait de quelques précieuses de
véhicules quelques précieuses ridicules
qu'ils ont fondé la revue
une telle qu'elle nous est il tremble
aider votre professeur oui tu avais mis
17 sur 20 ouais donc c'est cette année
qui va selon écrivain détester parce que
c'était la question suivante tu t'en
doutes réagissait même si je m'attendais
à mieux
et maintenant je vois un homme une voix
bugey khartoum avait conduit le vous
rencontre avec notre rigueur jamais
assez logique au tce est simplement je
supporte pas qu'il ait pas eu des gens
est devenu ce piètre personnages hantés
par le show business qui est l'homme
politique le plus génial pour toi c'est
que mon frère mais il faut attendre il
faut attendre
ouais parce que à force de penser comme
un pied de james et si ton frère à
l'époque où il était ministre de la
culture au lieu de refuser de te voir
finalement s'était plus montré avec toi
est ce qu'il aurait pas eu une meilleure
image que je pensais parce que c'est
tout ce qui lui mon toit pour son animal
tout compris oui mais tu aurais dû faire
partie de la marne aller aussi loin de
faire partie de la bande à léo était
déjà partie de la grande armée que
l'homme politique le plus nul la liste
se prend au jeu pour affreux ce qui se
passe dans ce pays en ce moment et
personne tout le monde et tout le monde
y est sensible et plus et puis c'est à
dire
fois que personne ne réagisse la
déception
jamais je t'en remercie mme sienne fait
par chance de venir à coeur tu es ma
famille a rendu de grands services à
vous - les facteurs bon alors on ne
l'attend pas dernière question là le mec
le plus génial ni acteur ni hommes
politiques des acteurs john stahl mes
livres vivants où on vient avec l'âge et
contemporains sont rares je voudrais tu
souhaites mai mais j'ai pris beaucoup de
temps j'ai maintenant à partir de ce
talent et chaque seconde et d'autres
considèrent comme un cadeau vingt-cinq
mille jours disait quincy jones oui le
mec le mec le plus nul de tous
il vous le dise le no way toutes
catégories peuvent et même si c'est un
beau gâchis humain et mary l'humiliante
personnes au collet du linge dealer est
il justement c'est pas grave
non mais je sais pas d'où avec le pull
mais je sais que je le rencontre souvent
c'est ça qui me fait peur c'est que le
mal le plus là mon avis les des
chenilles qui commencent à proliférer